bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur un
terreau france vous êtes infirmier
anesthésiste au chu henri-mondor à
créteil la région ile de france où l'on
redoute ces prochaines semaines
la saturation des hôpitaux comment est
ce que vous avez accueilli hier soir
l'annoncé par emmanuel macron du
couvre-feu est ce que selon vous ça va
dans le bon sens pour limiter la
deuxième vague bon sens dans le sens du
côté du collectif du côté je suis pas du
côté social mais nous dans les hôpitaux
il ya rien n'y a rien du tout de concret
qui a été avancé je les emmenais on a ce
sentiment amer d'avoir été trahis
d'avoir été abusés par ce ségur où les
revendications elles étaient on ne peut
plus simple pour vous les du monde
on me l'a donné du matériel mais il ya
quelqu'un derrière c'est pas la
métaphore est peut-être un petit peu
brutal mais c'est comme si vous aviez la
plus belle et voiture la plus
performante mais dedans vous mettiez pas
le chauffeur donc votre voiture est à
l'arrêt reste au parking voilà on est
dans cette situation alors l'allocution
de doigts hier soir elle n'a strictement
elle est concrètement rien apporté de
plus en tout cas nous a pas du tout
éclairée sur sur le devenir de ce qu
guide sens c'est par ici
mais c'est dramatique c'est dramatique
et malgré tout ce qui est visé avec ce
couvre feu c'est la jeunesse auront sec
le virus se propage très rapidement
parmi eux alors très souvent les cas
sont à sont asymptomatiques mais le
risque est évidemment qu'il le
transmette à des personnes fragiles est
ce que cette mesure ne va pas retarder
une programme propagation d'épidémies
malgré tout et donc du coup faire en
sorte que cette saturation des hôpitaux
qu'on redoute tant ils nous présentent
pas les chiffres sont là s'il 60% de la
contamination se fait soit au travail
soit dans le milieu scolaire
il sait pas la nuit que les étudiants
vont bosser ou dans les hôpitaux il ya
des personnels qui travaillent de nuit
mais c'est pas la majorité donc oui
c'est on a l'impression que c'est que le
monde le monde réel bien se percuter
avec le monde
démagogique de la bac ronnie on est un
peu surpris de ces mesures de couvre-feu
savez on a entendu on a vu partout qu'il
y avait eu un bénéfice en guyane donc je
pense qu'ils se sont appuyés sur ces
expériences là mais concrètement en
ile-de-france et dans les grosses
métropoles oui c'est les façons il ya
des décisions à prendre
à mon sens je pense qu'on ne s'est pas
assez servi de ce qui s'est passé sur la
première vague et toute la répercussion
il y avait matière il ya eu un exercice
grandeur nature qui a été fait sur tout
le territoire national et même sur le
territoire européen
y avait il y avait des leçons à tirer de
ça on les a pas fait fuir les leaders
eia ils n'y sont pas on apprend dans
certains certains hôpitaux confirment
même certains services pour pouvoir
déplacer le personnel et les mettre dans
les services ont fait le plus chaud où
c'est plus tendu
voyez en espèces de 2 d'ambiance de
chaises musicales coiffe assez en la
pressant de vivre une parodie de quelque
chose mais sauf qu'au bout il ya quand
même des morts il ya des patients qui en
heure il ya des choix stratégiques et
sanitaires qui ont été pris nous en tout
cas on est au front
puisqu'on reprendre la première
allocution monsieur macro nous étions en
guerre
on avait beaucoup d'espoirs sur le ségur
à la première journée du ségur on a
compris que c'était sale est une
fumisterie s'est pas présenté prévoyez
quinze mille embauches avec un choc
d'attractivité c'était le terme quel
bilan
est-ce que vous tirez aujourd'hui est-ce
que vous avez davantage de renforts
visiblement non mais non d'autant plus
que techniquement nous aviez deux
clusters qui était nationaux qui étaient
et le bassin enfin la région est de
france et la région ile de france ce qui
a permis d'avoir les de fer font à cette
première vague de qu'ovide c'est que
juste avant tous ces professionnels de
la santé qui étaient dans des provinces
qui n'était pas infecté par le cos vides
ont pu amener un vent fort sauf que
maintenant on n'est plus du tout dans ce
cadre là dans la mesure où tous les
clusters sont représentés dans les
territoires la preuve c'est que le
couvre-feu touche à certains nombre de
métropoles et pas des mois et nous rend
fort venait de ces métropoles
c'est à dire que là on va affronter la
deuxième vague en ayant en ayant déjà
comment dire un déficit de personnel un
déficit de l'hydre et à parce que
concrètement ce qu'on est en train de
subir la en 2020
c'est cette politique de casse public
qui a eu lieu pendant toute ces quarante
années
voyez et là on est en train de payer
cash cette structure 7 comment cette
politique sanitaire qui a été plus une
déstructuration de l'hôpital public une
qu'un maintien ou même une évolution de
l'hôpital public
on va très clairement vers un hôpital
privé on le voit bien le plan de la
santé l'eau ou le plfss 2020 vaz sur
cette orientation là et nous on est plus
qu'inquiets l'hôpital public c'est un un
joyau de notre république
il faut absolument le protéger on
comprend à vous entendre vous êtes
fatigué aujourd'hui vos conditions de
travail ne se sont visiblement pas
amélioré c'est ce que vous dites qu'elle
est dans ce contexte le risque aussi
pour la prise en charge des patients il
va être dramatique jeu
je veux pas être alarmiste mais bon je
lisais la dernière ce lot de l'ordre
infirmier qui annonce que 15 % des
infirmiers seul partir de l'hôpital
s'ils font les chiffres qui font ce
moment moi je n'ai pas vérifié ça c'est
les chiffres de l'ordre infirmier mais
ce que je sais c'est que nous par
exemple à l'hôpital henri mondor de
créteil on est en train de déposer en a
déposé un préavis de grève parce que
justement les personnels soignants sont
épuisés ils sont épuisés physiquement
mais ils sont surtout épuisé
psychologiquement
vous savez nous on n'a pas cette
sémantique ou cette rhétorique de
discours pro militaire mais n'empêche
que on nous a mis et on vous a qualifié
de héros nous a qualifiés de soldats de
l'ombre parce que nous étions combat
nous étions en guerre pour reprendre les
termes de monsieur mâcon mais il va y
avoir il ya des traumatismes post
traumatique qui sont en train de se
dessiner on a de plus en plus de
personnels qui sont en berne à août ils
sont fatigués il y en a qui se cachent
ils n'osent pas avouer qu'ils pleurent
qui parce que c'est très très très
culpabilisant est très déstabilisant
mais on va sur ce cadre là et les
responsables moi je pèse mes mots mais
les responsables sont ces gouvernements
sur moi aussi des directions qui qui qui
qui tape et qui sont très répressif sur
sur certains mais je suis mais je suis
amer je suis vraiment la merde parce que
la première vague quand vous avez décidé
de déposer plainte ce sera le mois de la
fin et on dépose pas plainte c'est que
on a posé des préavis de grève parce que
il faut aussi que cette après midi on a
eut manifesté et jeu mais voilà j'ai
même pas encore eu ce matin je suis pas
encore arrivé à mon hôpital mais on n'a
pas encore vu les chiffres
je pense que les personnels ont été
assignés encore à des chiffres qui sont
aberrants alors oui il ya les personnels
via les malades à soigner mais il ya
aussi il faut prendre conscience que
tant que le personnel soignant sera en
difficulté et sera dans le maire on
pourra pas soigner correctement
merci beaucoup pour votre témoignage
eric tricot infirmiers anesthésistes et
membre du syndicat sud santé